fire 20:19 has already been an amazing
year for new anime and the one anime
that I find myself looking forward to
the most every single week is without a
doubt the promised Neverland this series
is a psychological thriller of the
highest quality and every single episode
seems to end on a cliffhanger sometimes
literally that makes you absolutely
horrified when you realize you have to
wait another seven days to see what
happens next as someone who hasn't read
the manga yet I came into this with a
completely blank slate and from the very
first episode I was hooked the first few
episodes of this anime and the ensuing
battle of wits instantly reminded me of
the epic mental showdowns of some of my
favorite animes such as Death Note and
Code Geass the promised Neverland may be
a shounen but it is not a battle Shonen
the characters don't solve their
problems with their fists or swords or
giant robots instead they have to find a
way out of their very extremely
messed-up situation
strictly through the use of their juicy
delicious brains sorry I had to anyway I
just know that I will be forced to read
the entire manga very soon I just can't
help myself for much longer so I wanted
to make this video while I can still
give you my genuine thoughts and
feelings on the anime and before my mind
is tainted by learning everything else
there is to know about the story and the
twisted world of the promised Neverland
if you're an anime only you can rest
assured that this video will not have
any manga spoilers and if you are among
a reader this video will give you a
glimpse into the mind of someone who
loves the series solely based on the
anime even though I will be joining you
in the manga reader Club very soon now
the first thing that struck me as soon
as I saw the first episode of the
promised Neverland was the drastic
dichotomy between two completely
different realities first we have the
reality that the children of the
orphanage know they seem to be living
carefree lives as a big happy family all
of their needs are met by their Guardian
mama and by everyone else helping each
other and they all live in a house that
is surrounded by idyllic and peaceful
nature these children all seem so
sheltered and carefree and when a little
girl named Courtney is selected to be
adopted from the orphanage the powerful
mixture of happiness and sadness that we
can see expressed by both
and the other children is deeply moving
on the one hand corny and the others are
happy that she will be adopted and have
a real family rather than being an
orphan but on the other hand the
children feel like they already are a
big family right there in the orphanage
and they don't want to be separated from
each other however even as we get these
heartwarming scenes of parentless
orphans who found a happy home together
and even as we appreciate the
beautifully depicted and strangely
calming nature that surrounds the
orphanage there are clear signs from the
very beginning that something isn't
right the children have never left the
grounds of the orphanage and going
beyond the tall steel gate is strictly
forbidden furthermore the children all
have creepy numbered tattoos on their
bodies and there is something deeply
unsettling about Mama's smile from the
very beginning when Emma and Norman two
of the older kids and our main
protagonists along with Rhea realized
that Kony the girl who is being adopted
forgot her beloved stuffed animal they
inadvertently stumble upon a terrifying
realization the orphanage is not an
orphanage at all the orphanage is
actually a farm for children who are
grown like cattle and then given to vile
demonic creatures to consume as food a
my Norman discovered that Kony has been
killed and they realized that they are
next all of them are just food for
demons and their brains in particular is
what the demons are interested in this
is why the children have all been
treated so well and allowed to live
happily in a calm and beautiful
orphanage the goal is not to fatten them
up physically like cattle but to get
them to develop their brains as much as
possible in as happy and stress-free an
environment as possible just so that
their brains would taste better there is
no way for me to fully convey the
implications of this revelation on the
psyche of Emma Norman and eventually the
other children imagine living your
entire life believing one reality and
being completely trusting of someone
mama
Isabella you believe that this person
this adult is your guardian that she is
essentially your mother the only parent
you've ever known you trust that she is
there to take care of you to keep you
safe you think that she loves you and
then you learned that literally all of
this was a lie were
the reality is the exact opposite of
what you thought mama isn't trying to
protect you
she is preparing you to be slaughtered
and consumed as food by grotesque demons
and what's more mama has been doing this
for years she has done it too corny and
to other children
children that you consider your siblings
and your family children you love as
your own brothers and sisters let's be
real there is hardly anyone in the world
who can even imagine this level of
betrayal and the psychological impact on
these children is staggering Emma
Norman Rhea and the other kids are faced
with a nearly impossible situation they
must find a way to escape the orphanage
the farm before any more of them are
taken to be slaughtered by the demons
but many of the children are far too
young to comprehend the gravity of the
situation and telling them what is
really going on would cause the type of
panic that mama would pick up on right
away many of the children are also too
young to be able to escape on their own
without significant help from the older
kids and that only adds to the
complexity of their predicament but Emma
Norman and Rhea know that even if they
succeed in escaping but are forced to
leave the other kids behind
security will be tightened and all of
the other children will be slaughtered
without exception they have to decide
whether to take all of the children with
them an option that is highly
impractical and borderline impossible or
to leave them all to die a brutal death
an option that is far more practical but
also too cruel for someone like Emma to
even fathom all of this sets up one of
the best scenarios and settings for a
psychological battle of wits in the
history of anime the older kids must
outmaneuver mama and her potential
allies such as sister Crona or any
potential supplies within the ranks of
the children while doing their best to
learn more about the outside world and
find a way out of the orphanage and that
is another reality that is incredibly
difficult for us who live in this age of
information technology to comprehend the
children don't know anything about the
outside world
is the outside world completely
controlled by demons are there other
humans out there how powerful are these
demons and do they have any weaknesses
are there any allies on the outside that
they can count on or
they completely alone in the world the
children can't look any of this up on
Wikipedia or call a friend and ask them
they are completely on their own and
they know that the reality in which they
exist at the orphanage is completely
controlled by the demons and their human
allies like mama the books that they get
to read are handpicked by their enemies
in an attempt to constantly control them
everything that they have learned
throughout the course of their lives was
carefully selected in order to keep them
docile and under control and they have
no way of contacting anyone on the
outside the only way that they can learn
about the outside world is by observing
the tiny section of the world that they
inhabit and by trying to get as much
information as possible out of mama and
sister cronic to people whose job is to
lead them all to their deaths it is such
a messed up situation and if this wasn't
just an anime and if any of us ever
found ourselves in a similar predicament
like for real it would be absolutely
horrifying in many ways a situation so
terrible is hard for us to even
comprehend much less accept and deal
with and yet the masterful pacing and
storytelling of the promised Neverland
anime keeps us on the edge of our seat
constantly as each episode brings a new
twist and turn the constant feeling of
suspense and mystery is the biggest
reason why I love this series and the
next episode cannot arrive soon enough
we desperately want answers about this
cruel world how did it come to this
why are innocent children being raised
on farms just to be slaughtered who are
these demons and how did they come to
possess so much power over the lives of
innocent humans why are some humans like
mama actively working together with the
demons and facilitating the terrible
things that they are doing is there
anyone out there who is fighting against
the demons and finally is there any hope
that Emma Norman Rhea and the others can
actually escape and even if they do is
there anything out there for them except
death and despair even though the
promised Neverland story includes demons
who consume the brains of innocent human
beings gore and physical violence are
not even close to being the scariest
things about this series the scariest
aspect of the promised Neverland is the
psychological terror that the children
are faced with everything they thought
they knew
suddenly crumbles to the ground their
greatest ally mama turns out to be their
worst enemy and the one thing that they
all have been taught to look forward to
the most being adopted turns out to be
the worst thing that anyone could
possibly imagine
and beyond the children I find the
concept of humans like mama and sister
Crone a truly terrifying one could
possibly be their motivation what could
they be thinking and what could drive
them to willfully raise dozens of
innocent children as their own just to
eventually escort them to their gruesome
death sure we can assume that humans who
collaborate with the demons do it in
order to save their own lives they
themselves are being threatened by the
demons but what kind of life can a
person live if they are responsible for
the kinds of atrocities that these
people are responsible for how sick
twisted and deranged must these humans
be to not only stand by and watch what
happens to these children but to
actively facilitate such Horrors on a
daily basis I'm sure that a lot of the
questions that I mentioned here have
already been answered in the manga and I
can't wait to find out for myself but as
far as the anime goes on its own merits
I have to say that the promised
Neverland has one of the best setups
that I've seen in any anime a setup that
can stand up there with the best of them
including Death Note assassination
classroom and monster there is a certain
beauty in the horrors of the promised
never land and by beauty I don't mean
just a natural beauty that the children
are surrounded with there is a certain
beauty in how this series explores the
human psyche and how it makes us think
about what it truly means to be human if
you suddenly learn that everything you
believed in all of your life was a lie
how would you handle it would you still
be the same person after coming to terms
with all these lies and betrayal could
you handle the horrifying truth or would
you crumble under the pressure and most
of all can you ever really trust anyone
these are the powerful questions that
the promise Neverland poses with each
passing episode and together with the
superb pacing and skillful storytelling
this makes for a truly entertaining
suspenseful and self-reflective
experience just try to ask yourself how
you would react if you were placed in
the same situation as
the children of the promise Neverland
and that single question and the answer
you give may actually teach you a thing
or two about yourself this series deals
with some very uncomfortable themes and
in many ways this type of content scares
me way more than playing physical
violence and gore but the horror
elements of the promised Neverland are
not just for shock value there is a
great suspenseful story in there there
are likable characters that we can't
help but root for and there are
mysteries that we desperately want to
see solve and that is why I am loving
the promise Neverland even though I will
never be able to trust anyone in a maid
outfit ever again
sorry RAM and the other one I always
forget her name if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell if you feel that videos like this
one provide value for you and you want
to support more you can check out our
patreon we recently revamped the whole
thing a big thank you to all of the
patrons supporting us right now
including our pro hero to your patrons a
seventeen ffvp the one and only
Gilgamesh and Kela
even donating a single dollar will give
you access to our special patron only
discord and you will see your name
appear in our videos so please if you're
interested check us out link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]